[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
how much
do you think you would pay
per share
Twitter you think we can crowdsource
to uh box out Elon Musk this is a this
is a this is [ __ ] stupid I can't even
believe we have to continue to talk
about Elon Musk buying anything that has
anything to do with Twitter
this is really [ __ ] dumb
um All or Nothing offer for I don't know
43 billion dollars or some [ __ ] the guy
can't even I mean it's not like the guy
just says 200 billion dollars
sitting around in a mattress somewhere
this is really [ __ ] stupid
really [ __ ] stupid everyone's losing
their minds oh my God the world's coming
to an end because
Lex Luthor Elon Musk is gonna
buy Twitter
I'm sure Twitter is having a meeting
right now
to release a statement of how do we best
tell Elon Musk to [ __ ] all the way off
he's not buying he's not gonna bite to
it and I'm sure we're gonna have Gabe
Sanchez co-host an executive producer
here at the Tony Michaels podcast come
on and tell me why this is a serious
deal
I don't I don't think this is [ __ ]
serious he supposedly bought his board
seat and they told him to go [ __ ]
himself
so now he's now he's gonna buy the whole
goddamn kitten caboodle
oh [ __ ]
and here we are we have to talk about
this [ __ ] because this dumb [ __ ]
has more money than he knows what to do
with and that's really that's really the
thing here that we need to take from
this
that's that's what we need to take from
this is we need a tax
these trillionaires because they're
gonna be trillionaires soon folks it's
not like they're you know oh Tony
there's no such thing as a trillionaire
you just wait a couple [ __ ] years
wait they'll be trillionaires before you
know it
trillionaires are you [ __ ] listening
to millionaires you know we we went we
roll back in time
and we were all like ow Millionaires and
billionaires like we were so concerned
about millionaires get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ]
trillionaires okay trillionaires and
they're all [ __ ] trending every last
one of them
Elon Musk Jeff Bezos Zuckerberg they're
all trending
Gates they're all all these trillionaire
and and they're not trillionaires yet
but they're on that road
they make more money than you'll ever
[ __ ] dream of in a gazillion
lifetimes
and we're worried about taxing them into
Oblivion and frankly the 43 billion
dollars that he says he's gonna buy
Twitter with which is a [ __ ] joke
it's a [ __ ] joke
the 43 billion dollars that he says he's
gonna buy Twitter with we [ __ ] gave
him that money and I mean we the
taxpayers
everyone thinks this stupid [ __ ]
electric cars or some [ __ ] and Tesla is
some kind of great private company it
was subsidized by the United States
government our tax dollars
hours
Jesus Christ
but here we are talking about old musky
breath
in cell Elon his himself you know he's
got the band of incel Misfits right like
they fight and cells love this [ __ ]
gay they [ __ ] love this guy I mean
because it's like their dream right
like their dream of growing up after
getting their ass kicked the entire time
they were in elementary and Junior High
in high school they hate women
because they treat women like [ __ ] and
can't get one or keep one or have a
relationship with one you know who the
[ __ ] I'm talking about you met these
guys you probably got a cousin your
cousin Daryl you know that in cell that
guy
oh I I I just like to be single
and celibate okay Daryl
that's elon's best buddy
that's who he panders to that's what
he's doing he's punking he's punking his
in-cell band of Misfits
really just [ __ ] with them more than
anything making them think that there's
gonna be some kind of oh Twitter's gonna
be a safe space again for free speech
when have you ever when have you ever
seen as long as you're not inciting
violence or spreading hate speech what
have you ever seen anyone kicked off I
mean you know if you [ __ ] you
you're getting twitmo a couple times
or are you your temporary suspended
I say just about anything I [ __ ] want
on Twitter
and everyone else does too have you seen
Twitter
oh we need free speech back on Twitter
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
number one Twitter is not a space for
free speech
it's not public it's not it's Twitter's
website it's their website they [ __ ]
own it the shareholders
own it and the board controls it it's
their website not yours dumb
[ __ ]
Chris in says his account was
permanently suspended I you know Chris
you're you're nice here in our chat but
I can imagine some of the stuff you
might say over on the on Twitter Chris
is our uh our local hate Watcher thank
Chris for for hate watching every single
day the entire episode Chris is here
do you want to give a shout out uh good
morning everyone good morning
uh Robin's here Margie's here Debbie
from Salt Lake is here
who else do we have here holy moly we've
got Kathy is here we got Patricia is
here from Facebook Daryl Daryl I'm sorry
Daryl I didn't mean uh Daryl says he's
from Missouri
probably not the same Daryl as the
cousin I'm really sorry dear Daryl from
Facebook is here Mary from Facebook
Forest is here from Facebook
we have Christina's here Crystal from
Facebook here Brenda is here
Lynn is here Naomi is here holy moly we
got Patty Anne here Suzanne is here good
morning everyone good morning you guys
know we broadcast if you're new and
you're listening new and you have never
heard the Tony Michaels podcast before
uh Fenty is here profense Supply is here
Scott is here
depressed gamer is here
Mike is here Jamie's here
there's so many folks here Nikki's here
good morning good morning good morning
Nikki from Texas
every single weekday Monday through
Friday
Monday through Friday two hours every
single weekday we are on YouTube Twitter
and twitch and now we broadcast from the
my dis touch Facebook page same time
same place
Facebook YouTube Twitter twitch noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
hours every single weekday every last
[ __ ] one of them Monday through
Friday
two hours we go through the Tweety
tweets and attorney Trends we bring in
great guests we have our co-host and
executive producer Gabe Sanchez with his
opinions
and I'm sure he's gonna have an opinion
about Elon Musk today what do you guys
think you think he's going to have an
opinion about Elon
Elon
oh you talk about a silver [ __ ] spoon
this guy this guy made his made his
bones his his poppy made his bones on
blood diamonds
and here he is trying to buy Twitter
this is where we're at in the world this
is the timeline that we're living in
and all because he wants to play with
the fact that his fans his followers
want that [ __ ] Maniac down in
Mar-A-Lago the Cheeto dust mobster
Grandpa Poopypants himself back on
Twitter
I mean you know what you know what
here's the thing I would almost rather
just give that fat slob his [ __ ]
account back I mean he's only four or
five Big Macs from a dirt nap
or or a couple months away from federal
indictments and having his fat bare feet
on a cold prison floor
so I give that [ __ ] his account
back
and tell Elon Musk to kick rocks that's
what I would do if I were Twitter maybe
you know if that's the goal here if
that's the [ __ ] goal
is to let Donald Trump tweet
can you imagine how insignificant and
irrelevant his tweets would be by now
you know you know the [ __ ] you
know the [ __ ] who leaves Twitter
for months and months and years
some kind of Scandal and then they try
to come back yeah [ __ ]
his account would be worthless
I mean it's it's probably all the fake
bot accounts are gone so his following
is probably down to half
no one even pays attention to his
statements anymore that people that they
tweet his statements they tweet his
[ __ ] statements out
and everyone's like ah [ __ ] that gay
that guy's a [ __ ] mess
[ __ ] grandpa needs to take a nap
again
after his three rounds of golf
hell [ __ ]
Elon Musk is buying Twitter
he attempts a Twitter coup that's the
title of our episode today episode
number 118.
118 episodes holy moly thank you so much
for 118 episodes
you guys know if you're if you're uh
listeners if you're new listeners though
let me explain
uh something about happens every week
this afternoon we're gonna put out the
bonehead of the week pole on Twitter so
go follow at Tony Michael's pod if
you're on Twitter if you're not go start
chin account over there you're going to
want to get one because boy is it gonna
be hot once Elon Musk owns that
[ __ ] so go go get you a Twitter
account why Twitter accounts are getting
good
you might want to secure your handle
all right go over to Twitter and follow
at Tony Michael's pot we will release
the bonehead of the week Pole
I wonder if Elon will make it on there
uh we got Charlie Kirk gonna be on there
because Charlie oh my God yesterday we
went we we got to do uh I don't know
it's 15 20 minutes on whop you know
cardi B song [ __ ] wet ass [ __ ] because
Ben Shapiro got punked speaking of being
punked got punked at some kind of uh
speaking event that he that he uh
and he and he got slammed at for his
prior comments about his wife's vagina
his comments Ben Shapiro not mine Ben
Shapiro's comments about his wife's
vagina
I don't know go look it up or you can go
watch yesterday's episode me and Gabe
describe it and break it down
him talking about his wife's vagina not
not Jesus you people need to calm down
so go go watch yesterday's episode 117
and I think it's titled Ben Shapiro is a
bozo but today today we're gonna break
down the Charlie Kirk video where he he
claims
the higher the building the more liberal
it is
[ __ ] I'm not [ __ ] you I'm not
[ __ ] you he said the higher the
taller a building is the more liberal it
is
it's liberal
because of the height of the building
he knows that his [ __ ] Cheeto God his
mango Mussolini Jesus claims that he
builds all kinds of high-rises and
skyscrapers right
like the guy they worship the people who
are like yeah
those big huge high rises and
skyscrapers are all libtard bastards
your your Cheeto dust mobster your
Mussolini Jesus your orange Mussolini
Jesus
the cult that you have the cult leader
that's what he claims he got rich off of
you dumb [ __ ]
holy actual you can't make this [ __ ] up
you can't make this [ __ ] up and they're
clapping like yeah yeah more more floors
on an apartment building the more
liberal it is
here's what Charlie Kirk is saying folks
and and I and we'll break it down on the
video but he's saying he's saying black
people live in really tall apartment
buildings is what he's saying white
people live in nice houses with big
yards that's what he's saying he's a
[ __ ] racist so we're gonna break that
down
we're gonna break that video down he
sounds really stupid because he is
[ __ ] really stupid but it's a racist
[ __ ] he's doing racist tropes racist
tropes now MJ is here Crystal's here
Brenda from Facebook is here Don
Facebook is here everybody's here this
morning this is fantastic welcome
welcome to the Tony Michaels podcast
right here on YouTube Twitter and twitch
and now on the Midas touch Facebook page
make sure do us a huge favor make sure
to go over to YouTube if you haven't
already and subscribe
to the podcast subscribe over there on
YouTube
it helps us out a lot and you can join
the super chat if you want to join the
Super Chat there on on YouTube
you can chat with us and you can send a
super sticker if you want and we'll
bring you in as you uh send super
stickers and super chats
Super Chat I need like a sound effect
for that either that I just did it do
Super Chat
it's fantastic fantastic
it's a good day today I don't know they
caught Frank James New York City
yesterday the uh the subway shooter he's
a crazy kook now yesterday we talked to
uh Karen agnipolo KFA of legal AF
GH and we talked to her yesterday if you
want to catch that part of that episode
you can go over and watch the uh Ben
Shapiro whop
section and you can go over and watch a
professional lawyer
describe to us now Frank James would be
arrested
um NYPD would arrest him promptly and
she was correct
kfa's prediction was spot the [ __ ] on
she did not miss with that one so go
over and watch yesterday's episode I'm
actually probably going to be posting
that interview separately today and then
we'll probably post up the uh maybe
we'll post up the Ben Shapiro whop wet
ass [ __ ] discussion that we had
yesterday
um that me and Gabe had we'll post that
up on YouTube so don't forget to
subscribe you're definitely going to
want to subscribe to the YouTube channel
you're not going to want to miss a thing
over there so please please do us that
favor and again
go to the Facebook page this afternoon
we'll have that uh
we'll have that bonehead of the week
pull for for the new listeners out there
bone end of the week is a very important
thing here on the Tony Michaels podcast
the audience it's a very important thing
like this is the thing we could not
manage
to continue in our democracy without the
bonehead
of the week
uh MJ said he turned himself in
not sure they get credit well you know
maybe they were on the hunt MJ
either way they caught him
they caught him
they got him that's the important thing
is the guy's in custody because we
watched the video yesterday where he was
just he's off the rails I mean this
guy's been on the rails for a long time
and and again he he was resorting to
vinelives wanted to resort to violence
to uh uh to try to you know
save something or segregate something he
really wanted he talked about a
segregated society and slavery and
it's um
sad situation when you think that
violence is a way to save democracy
to save our country from fascism
democracy is the answer that's the
answer democracy is the answer not not
violence violence is not the answer and
that's why the violent Insurrection was
unsuccessful the Cheeto dust kangaroo
coup was unsuccessful
because that's not the way you save our
country
I mean they were delusional and they're
saving quote unquote that's why they got
violent
I forget who it was but I think it was a
representative from Michigan at the last
Nazi rally excuse me uh Trump rally not
the last one maybe the time before that
or I don't know they have a [ __ ]
rally every goddamn two the second
Tuesday of every week
every [ __ ] week they have a goddamn
Nazi rally but there was a a a a
congresswoman from Michigan who said uh
weakness breeds aggression and they're
like the most aggressive [ __ ]
in the country they tried to overthrow
our government with violence
killing police officers you know the
black back the blue crowd killing police
officers to try to finally overthrow our
constitution so yeah weakness does breed
aggression when weakness is in charge
that's what happens that's why we're not
seeing we're not seeing huge pockets of
of libtards trying to take over parts of
the country with violence
we don't see them going in the school
board meetings and elbowing their
weighing in and threatening school board
members because CRT voodoo
we don't see that we don't see them
threatening to bomb nuclear power plants
and shut down electrical grids like Adam
Waffen the neo-nazis groups on the right
wing
I mean this really really she's correct
she is correct that [ __ ] wackadoo
that weakness breeds aggression it
certainly does
and it seems Frank James's weakness was
that he thought a segregated Society
was the answer that you know blacks and
whites shouldn't live together and he he
was talking in in forms of some sort of
like racial War a race war almost
um and that's what these neo-nazis
that's what these insurrectionists
that's what these pedocon Republican kid
diddlers want
they want to race war they wanted it on
January 6th me and KFA talked about this
yesterday on the show
that was the lead into the January 6
select committee and the January 6
conversation that we had yesterday
that we had yesterday
was that weakness breeds aggression
because certainly Frank James weakness
bred his aggression
so much so that he was willing to go to
a subway car I you know this is the
thing that we questioned yesterday why
and maybe we'll find out
hopefully we'll find out why he chose a
subway car in New York City it really
does not make a lot of sense
as if the subway car was some sort of
white supremacist Bastion you know like
this is where they hung out or something
I'm not saying white supremacists don't
hang out on a subway car in New York
City but God damn you're really unlikely
to pick pick a group of neo-nazis out on
a subway car in New York City I would to
be frank
there's a hell of a lot easier places in
this country to maybe throw a stone and
hit a Neo-Nazi I'm just saying
you know what I mean
but it's very strange that he picked a
subway car in New York City
but of certainly his weakness bred his
aggression just like these [ __ ] Trump
humping magas and these spreadnicks he's
insurrectionist he's pedocon Republican
kid diddlers
let me continue
they continue
to have their weakness breed aggression
I mean they're [ __ ] terrified
terrified oh
lgbtq people the community of gays oh
they're so scary they're gonna
take over our country
and I don't know what the [ __ ] they
think
leave them the [ __ ] alone they're not
bothering you
they're terrified absolutely terrified
of gay people weakness
breeds aggression that's where the
aggression comes from
they're absolutely terrified
that the law is going to prevent them
from diddling kids terrified of it
terrified so terrified they're trying to
pass laws so they can take your consent
away and marry your children
in Tennessee Missouri I mean they're all
trying to out Florida really we're going
to watch another [ __ ] despicable
thing from Tennessee today another
[ __ ] despicable video from the
Tennessee legislator
where some [ __ ] I don't know who
this guy is
talking about Hitler and how Hitler was
homeless
and the Hitler con and the homeless can
strive to be Hitler I mean look at
Hitler he was homeless and he became a
great success or some [ __ ] I don't know
this [ __ ] [ __ ] is nuts they've lost
their goddamn Minds
like I've been saying the last week it's
a q Anon World folks we're just [ __ ]
living in it
whoosh
so hang tight
we're gonna go through the Tweety tweets
and the trendy Trends today and yes we
are going to talk about a shitload of
trillionaires and I know I know their
bank accounts aren't trillions yet but
they soon will be May will soon be
trillionaires mark my words don't doubt
me
You're Gonna Go ow he was right they're
[ __ ] trillionaires of course they're
trillionaires why I mean
that's that's their whole goal here is
to be trillionaires
that's what they want
so hang tight we're gonna go through the
Tweety tweets and the trendy trends
in just a few minutes
and we're probably gonna have a Gabe
join us let's see where he's at let's
let's get it send him a message
see when he's coming on
you guys see the new thumbnail of the
Elon Musk
Gabe did a thumbnail up on um on Twitter
on the Twitter announcement oh it's
beautiful
it's a beautiful announcement go go
retweet it's got the link to the show
here again we come to you every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central on YouTube Twitter
twitch and now from the Midas touch
Facebook page
go follow us on YouTube give us a like
share it retweet it
spread it around the internet like
herpes
spread it around Twitter because we
don't know how long this shit's gonna be
here with Elon Musk trying to attempt a
Twitter coup let's start the countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Michaels podcast we've reached a part of
the show where we round up all the
Tweety tweets and Eternity trends of the
day
but shitless Roundup the shitlist
Roundup
so let's uh dive into the uh to the
timeline here and let's see what let's
see what we have
let's see what we have here
um we got uh several videos that I want
to um to go through today let's make
this a little bigger so y'all folks can
seize you can seize what I'm searching
here
um
you guys know down in Texas we watched a
video yesterday of uh Beto O'Rourke he's
uh running running for governor of the
state of Texas and he's only two points
behind apparently in a poll if you
believe polls
you know he's only like two points
behind
yeah
Rachel says here the Republican Greg
Abbott is on a one-man mission to drive
up our food cost Greg Abbott is the
current governor
of the State of Texas and if you watched
yesterday you saw a video a better
O'Rourke standing at the border
at the Columbia Bridge at a crossing and
there's all kinds of trucks backed up as
far as the eye could see that's his
words
waiting to enter our country with Goods
that need to go on shelves
a lot of produce Vehicles TVs
Electronics a lot of stuff that's
manufactured
in Mexico but produce and food and
Rachel's making a good point here
Republican Greg Abbott the pedocon the
kid diddler Greg Abbott
is trying to drive up your food cost
and empty your grocery grocery store
shelves so I called him old empty
shelves Abbott
that's what they're trying to do because
they wanna they wanna drive up cost they
want to they want to empty your grocery
store shelves they want to create this
image
of backup and the supply chain the
supply Chain's broken well yeah you
[ __ ] broke it because here's what's
happening in Texas see the feds control
the the Border it's a federal border see
the federal government controls the
Border
between Mexico and the United States
right it just happens that part of that
border is in Texas
well the feds have the ability to
actually check these trucks
um whether it be drugs any kind of other
paraphernalia or or humans that might be
trying to get across the border inside
these trucks they have the ability to
search the inside cargo got it the feds
have the ability to search their cargo
well what Greg Abbott is doing is on the
other side of the Border just on our
side he's having the Texas Highway
Patrol as it were
check the tire pressure
on these trucks make sure you know they
pass they pass road inspection
they can't check the cargo they don't
have the ability nor nor do they have
the equipment nor the Manpower but they
do in fact have the have the ability to
bottleneck the entire
the entirety of entering the country
with Goods
that we rely on food
food Greg Abbott is trying to starve
your children are you hearing me
he's trying to empty your shelves at the
grocery store not just in Texas folks
this food just doesn't go to Texas this
food goes all around the country
so when you go when you go and can't get
your guacamole
yeah it's Greg Abbott is the reason why
empty shelves Abbott is the reason why
that is the reason why
we have empty shelves at the grocery
store if you go to the grocery store and
you see a shelf empty I don't care what
it is
dead manner to me it's because Greg
Abbott is bottlenecking and killing our
supply chain
or as the former guy would say Supply
changes yeah the supply changes down
there in Texas are not doing very well
and he's intentionally doing it again
what they're trying to do
what they're trying to do is is create a
crisis right that's the whole [ __ ]
Republican pedocon kid diddler way is a
manufacturer crisis and then they try to
blame it on Democrats
well I mean really honestly if Greg
Abbott is so [ __ ] intelligent and
he's so in charge of the border which
he's not if he was then why why wouldn't
he be just be able to click his frame
fingers and and fix it
just like the former guy was going to
make our country great again in four
years and he [ __ ] tanked that son of
a [ __ ] and now they're out there
[ __ ] saying oh he's got to make it
great again again and again and again
and again well if he made it great again
in the four years we already gave him
and why the hell is our country in such
a [ __ ] then
by their standards right
so again
this is a one-man Mission like Rachel
says here to drive up your food cost you
want to know who to blame in favor
inflation on blame it on empty shelves
Abbott that's who you blame it on Old
empty shelves Greg Abbott okay
Lindsey Simmons uh points out a good
makes a good point
about Elon Musk you know Elon Musk
bought as like 9.2 percent of Twitter
and it was like three what is it three
billion he bought or some [ __ ]
he spent three billion dollars to buy
nine percentage and that's probably all
he really could afford
uh to try to buy a seat on the board
any day they wouldn't let him have a
seat on the board
and you got mad you got pissed off well
you sons of [ __ ] while just buy the
whole goddamn thing then how do you like
that how you like that you [ __ ]
but Lindsay points points it makes a
good observation here never trust anyone
who is eager to pay 43 billion to avoid
a background check because apparently
the reason why Elon Musk couldn't get a
seat at the board is because he couldn't
pass their background check which is not
surprising
not surprising
at all
oh here's this video of this uh this
this this this Senator it's a Tennessee
senator Frank nicely oh [ __ ] his name is
nicely you can't trust a guy whose last
name is nicely I don't care who you are
and if there's any nicelys here in the
chat I'm really sorry
uh senator Frank nicely here of
Tennessee we're gonna we're gonna go
through um we're gonna watch that video
here in just a bit
um Aaron says of the Elon Musk offers to
buy Twitter
says he can unlock
it's extraordinary potential so Elon
Musk can unlock the extraordinary
potential Twitter because you know the
extraordinary potential of Twitter is
just I'm it's just locked away
no one's tweeting no one's engaging
there isn't that many people on Twitter
I mean it really isn't even that
powerful really if you think get the
[ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ] that
you're gonna unlock the extraordinary
potential of Twitter
it's the users that unlock the
extraordinary potential of Twitter you
dumb [ __ ] why don't these
fascists why don't these these these
dumb [ __ ] incels
understand
that human beings Humanity
is the extraordinary potential of
everything
it doesn't matter what it is
Humanity in the humans are what gives
us our extraordinary potential whether
it's our country whether it's a company
whether it's an organization a
non-profit whether it's it's it's giving
Aid to Ukraine the human aspect of
everything is the extraordinary
potential
how in the [ __ ] can't these idiots
understand that
Elon Musk shits all over his employees
shits all over them
oh California's to blame
for making me make sure my employees are
safe you remember this during during the
pandemic
he was complaining and whining and
bitching that he had to spend money
he had to spend money to keep his
employees from not making sure they get
sick
you just pissed off
yet here he is gonna buy Twitter
at the flick of a wrist
for 43 billion but he can't afford to
make sure his employees were safe during
the pandemic come on
and this is the guy who whines and
complains about that
and he's wondering standing around
wondering why something oh the
extraordinary potential of something
it's the humans
it's the humans it's the employees it's
the workers
it's the people who are in the
organization that's what is the
extraordinary potential
without that there is no potential at
all no one gives a flying [ __ ] nobody
Elon Musk offers to buy Twitter to
unlock the extraordinary but they get
the [ __ ] out of here Aaron says good
news
for fans of Hitler memes
so Aaron is surmising here that if Elon
Musk buys
Twitter that the Hitler memes will be
back in full force uh outspoken says
Twitter's board is meeting at 10 A.M to
discuss Elon Musk takeover offer per
CNBC
so that's the news
um outspoken says see at 1001 am Maybe
maybe maybe not depends on what they
decide I think this uh this board
meeting
that they're gonna have
to discuss this offer because it's an
all or nothing offer this is why it's a
joke this is why it's all [ __ ] this
is why it's not serious it's because
this is not how a 43 billion dollar
transaction happens you don't take a
public company and offer 43 billion
dollars that you just don't have laying
around and offer them 43 billion dollars
take it or leave it it's not a serious
thing if Elon Musk was really serious
about buying Twitter if he was really
serious about it he would be [ __ ]
serious
what I mean by that is he would procure
the the actual illusion of the financing
like he can't just [ __ ] [ __ ] out 43
billion dollars that's not how it works
he doesn't just have 43 billion sitting
in a [ __ ] safe somewhere I mean this
isn't Scrooge McDuck I mean he's close
but he doesn't have the tower full of
money that he swims in
it's not a thing that he has I mean his
wealth is built up and and not just cash
so this just take it or leave it thing
is the where the [ __ ] starts
the horse [ __ ]
that this offer is that's where it
begins is when he says take it or leave
it that's not how you would buy Twitter
I mean if there was actually a buyer out
there that was interested in Twitter
then they would be serious about it a
lot of people are comparing this to to
Bezos buying newspapers well Jeff Bezos
is is serious about buying newspapers
and buying media Outlets like he's
serious about it they make serious
offers they do serious Deals they don't
just tweet it out send in a a form and
you're gonna buy Twitter and then tweet
it out I made my offer
take her leave it [ __ ]
you think Twitter is gonna be very
receptive to a take it or leave it offer
that they don't get to negotiate they
don't get to say well what are the terms
don't we get to offer any terms of
ourself
the [ __ ] are you talking about so that's
why it's all [ __ ] that's why Elon
Musk this is not serious it's all PR
things so we'll sit here and talk about
it which we are so congratulations Elon
Musk you took up a whole day
made us waste our [ __ ] time
um I said that guy who won't take no for
an answer you know the guy you've met
These Guys these guys that won't take no
for an answer you know like um oh there
was a guy who ran for president one time
and um he was on an Access Hollywood bus
and he said something like you know
you just grab him by the [ __ ] they let
you do that kind of stuff when you're
famous right
yeah you know just grab them by the
[ __ ] you remember that guy he ran for
president I don't know what happened to
him apparently he's eating Big Macs down
in South Florida right now
but that guy that guy won't take no for
an answer that's Elon Musk there's a lot
of guys out there
and they all seem to
brood on the one side of our politics uh
Amy Lynn says uh Elon Musk can go [ __ ]
himself
I mean just really just keep it simple
you know what I mean just keep it simple
when you're tweeting folks because if
Elon does buy Twitter you're definitely
not going to be able to tweet this
you really think if Elon Musk buys
Twitter you'll be aiming Lynn will be
able to tweet Elon Musk can go [ __ ]
himself
you really think that come on he will
not let people tweet Elon Musk can go
[ __ ] himself
he just wouldn't do it he's too weak
I mean Jesus Christ he [ __ ] and
whines and moans about pain a little bit
a small percentage of the money he has
in taxes oh they're gonna they're gonna
make me pay they're gonna make me pay
pittance after they gave me all kinds of
federal subsidies to get my electric car
company going
whine whine cry cry shut the [ __ ] up you
whiny little [ __ ] you don't think he's
gonna keep you from from saying the
things you want to say on Twitter
Amy Lynn would not be able to say Elon
Musk and go [ __ ] himself if Elon Musk
owns Twitter privately no [ __ ] way no
[ __ ] way I mean Jesus Christ we see
we see true social the [ __ ]
the failed plane crash that was
and the only reason why is because they
put that weak ass [ __ ] Devin Nunes in
charge of that thing yeah he's a weak
ass punk ass [ __ ] Devin Nunes gives up
his congressional seat to go over to
make sure
that there's not Devin Nunes and cow in
the same handle
and he tanked he tanked true social
tanked it
yeah okay
okay we want these we want these weak
ass crybaby in cells to take over
Twitter and they think that's going to
be a good idea come on
Kate says who thinks Elon Musk can [ __ ]
off I mean really you see you see the
pattern here do you see the pattern
Elon Musk can [ __ ] all the way off all
the way the whole way and just keep
going don't stop keep [ __ ] off Elon
don't quit
we'll be right behind you buddy
[Laughter]
you I am speaking for the Tweet uh Midas
Touch has a new video and we'll get to
this uh here in a little bit Putin's
party hashtag Putin's party uh it's very
um you guys know we're we we are
partners of mightiest touch
we're broadcasting live on minus touch
Facebook page go follow us on YouTube as
well the Tony Michaels podcast you
search that on on YouTube and subscribe
there but we are broadcasting live right
now on the minus touch Facebook page
we're partners of my search but we're
going to show this video because video
is very powerful because it is
it helps describe our politics and our
country
with the contrast of what is happening
in Ukraine where that murderous [ __ ]
dictator Vladimir Putin is murdering
innocent women and children and innocent
civilians committing war crimes
and all the while the Republican party
is continuing to spread his propaganda
continuing to support people continuing
to prop people up
who are Putin sympathizers so we will
watch that also we're going to watch
this video here in a bit of Sean Hannity
last night speaking of speaking of
Putin's puppets
yeah the former guy the Cheeto dust
mobster Grandpa poopy pants himself uh
called in called it in last night on the
Hannity Show
and he couldn't he couldn't bring
himself
to criticize Putin that's why it's
Putin's party Putin's runs it man Putin
is the head of the pedocon Republican
kid diddler party the gqp wants the GOP
the grand o pedophiles that are the
Republicans
you want to marry your children
and they're okay with Vladimir Putin
murdering murdering innocent civilian
and committing war crimes in Ukraine
they're okay with it I mean you know
it's for a good cause it's to kill
democracy for crying out loud
Putin wants to kill democracy were for
him right and we don't care how he does
it just so we can kill democracy and
marry children that's what the
Republicans are about that's all they
can focus on is sexualizing your kids
gender and marrying children and making
sure that Putin destroys democracy that
way all the while they have the ability
to marry your children and take your
consent away from your children don't
doubt me they're trying to take your
consent away from your children
go look at some of these Tran anti-trans
bills that they're trying to pass
and these state legislators they're
trying to take parents consent away
from them about their children and then
they went to marry them
it's really [ __ ] stupid Andrea Andrea
tweets here
um number one Elon Musk pumps up
Twitter's stock prices oh yeah he he he
he says he's gonna buy it overpriced
right so he says he says he's gonna buy
it for a certain price which is almost
ten dollars more a share than what it's
listed at this morning now number two
Elon Musk sells his Holdings
for some trumped-up reason yeah so so
like you'll he'll he'll pump the price
the price will go up and then you know
that that nine percent that he bought
the other day
don't you see how this is working out
that nine percent he bought the other
day he'll be like oh [ __ ] Twitter they
don't want me well I'll sell my stock
and I'll I'll tank I'll tank their stock
prices by selling off my shares he's
already threatening to do that number
three Elon Musk at that point walks away
with a hefty profit on that nine percent
do you see what do you see what's
happening this isn't rocket science it's
a pump and dump scheme he's not wanting
to buy Twitter he's wanting to sell his
stock folks
that's why that's why it's an all or
nothing offer
he knows Twitter isn't going to take
this offer seriously because it's not a
serious offer he knows that but all the
people out there all the people out
there that think it's serious boy
they're gonna go by Twitter he's going
to buy Twitter and it's gonna make the
stock rise
all of a sudden
and then he's going to dump his 9.2
percent chair that he bought last week
and we had to talk about this [ __ ] last
week you know really honestly maybe
maybe we should do a federal
investigation into Elon Musk
and his and his uh his investment habits
I don't know
I don't know let's just see if it's
criminal or not it could possibly be
Andrew thank you for Andrea thank you
for your Tweet I think you're spot on
here I think this is a pump and dumb
scheme it's not a serious offer
uh Hamish says Greg Abbott proved to be
a bigger [ __ ] than Ted Cruz this week
impressive that is impressive because he
is an [ __ ] they're both [ __ ] and
they're both from Texas I that doesn't
have anything to do with it it just it's
just that's a coincidence
Texas can do better and they are doing
better did you see that
Beto O'Rourke is two points away two
points away
from Greg Abbott
that's within swinging distance folks
you talk about getting registered and
getting out the vote in Texas
if if we could clone Stacy Abrams and
get her and get us Stacey Abrams in
Texas by God I bet better O'Rourke when
the good news is you all
y'all down in Texas
I want to make sure that that empty
shelves Abbott the guy who's trying to
stop food from coming in this country so
you can have your grocery store shelves
full
that guy all the electronics that he's
preventing from coming in this country
that we have trade deals with he's
trying to empty your shelves empty
shelves Avid that guy
if you wanna if you don't like that
[ __ ] well go out register people
to vote find the Beto campaign
go put out signs go knock on doors
do what you can do to save your
democracy not just the country but your
State's democracy as well now Mayo says
one of our favorites here Mayo says good
morning to everyone who thinks Elon Musk
is an [ __ ] good morning Mayo
ah good morning Mayo
oh did you hear the news yesterday did
you hear the news Mark Meadows
some people thought I was serious when I
said this Mark Meadows is moving quote
unquote to The Villages where he'll
register to vote you guys seen that the
um this at the state of North Carolina
told him to get [ __ ] and pulled his um
his voter registration which they should
charge him with voter fraud and you've
seen that yesterday then the same day
that the two the two white dudes the two
old white ball sacks down in The
Villages at Florida who committed voter
fraud in the name of trump and the name
of their Jesus Mussolini
orange Jesus Mussolini their Cheeto dust
mobster they voted for Trump twice they
committed voter fraud a judge that piece
of [ __ ] judge down there only gave him
community service you should lock those
[ __ ] up
we've been yelling and screaming about
voter fraud like literally the entire
[ __ ] half of the country that is the
Republican pedocons the kid dealers have
been yelling and screaming about voter
front they've been having conferences
they had a cyber Symposium they
literally have content hours and hours
and 24 7 that's built around Russian
propaganda that the election was stolen
and there was voter fraud and all this
nonsense
and they catch the they catch the few
people that committed voter fraud in
2020.
they're Trump supporters because they
tried to vote for Trump twice and they
give them community service
really
you're so [ __ ] upset so [ __ ] upset
about a stone election and voter fraud
and but you're not upset that the people
who actually committed voter fraud got
community service
come on get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
lock these [ __ ] up but I made
the joke
Mark Meadows because he lost his voter
registration
in North Carolina he might want to move
to the Villages down in Florida that way
you know I mean he could register three
or four times
you know if you're gonna commit voter
fraud he might as well do it right
I'm just saying
um here is the video of Charlie Kirk
that we're probably going to we're going
to look at this video here in a little
bit uh Gabe tweeted about it
about the buildings and the high rises
I'm Charlie Kirk uh he he thinks the
higher the building the more floors the
building has
the more liberal it is and the more
disgusting it is the more it destroys
our country
look at them them socialism scack
scrapers
I'll tell you what he's talking about
here because he talks about how houses
and yards but when we watch this video
I'll tell you what he's saying I'll tell
you what he's saying and it's [ __ ]
racist is what he's saying
and that's why the crowd cheers
and that's why everyone's really excited
about this narrative because this
narrative that he's trying to push here
about how how we want we want the
Suburbia it's a it's a racist Trope that
he's doing and that's what it is
and it's what it is uh Ken says
community service are you [ __ ]
kidding me I wouldn't I wouldn't [ __ ]
you Ken I would not [ __ ] you Ken you are
my favorite turd I'm telling you they
got community service and they have to
take some sort of civics class you're
talking about these [ __ ] boneheads
down at The Villages now there's four of
them that were charged with voter fraud
two of them yesterday received their
sentence from the judge
and the sentence was
community service I think it was 50
hours or some [ __ ] who cares how many
hours it was it's community service lock
those [ __ ] up like I said we've
been dealing with this [ __ ] where you
people been yelling and screaming about
voter fraud for two goddamn years
two years they've been yelling about it
and it's been two years because it was
even before the election that they were
yelling about voter fraud and election
being stolen mail-in ballots and double
dead people voting and on and on and on
and [ __ ] goes and on with the
delusion and the [ __ ] and the lies
and the Russian propaganda can convince
you of queuing on [ __ ]
and here we are the [ __ ] voter fraud
that we find they get community service
all the while all the while last
election there was a young lady in Texas
who was sentenced to a prison sentence
not because she committed intentionally
committed voter fraud she
unintentionally
didn't have her voter registration the
way it should be they could have just
threw the ballot out they could have
gave her community service but they
didn't they imprisoned her and the
reason why is because she's black
she's black
she committed voter fraud
while being black so they imprisoned her
the two old white dudes in Florida in
The Villages
who intentionally and committed voter
fraud not unintentionally not
inadvertently they voted twice it was
intentional
it gave him community service in a
civics class and no kin I'm not [ __ ]
kidding you I wouldn't [ __ ] you you're
my favorite turd
people these people
all right let's move on here dude what
else do we have what else do we have on
the agenda oh hey here's a good here's a
good thing uh Adam Epstein you guys know
dirty moderate we had Adam we had Adam
on our show
a while back I think it was in December
we had Adam on we played we played
American history trivia with Adam he's a
Tony Award winner
but Adam has a podcast called Dirty
moderate
um he invited me on his podcast and uh
here's a here's a clip of it
um play and I think Republicans let's
see if we can
play it here it drops
um April 15th I believe on all your
podcast directories so Spotify Apple
Google all those directories it drops on
those directories but it's dirty
moderate with Adam Epstein
and that is on April 15th let's listen I
think there's there's two different
things at play and I think Republicans
have always done this really well
there's politics right for elections and
then there's governing right and they
know that Republicans not just the
politicians but also the voters know
that those are two separate things those
things are not the same those are two
different than government and politics
are two different things now they kind
of play with each other right but
they're two different things Democrats
do not do that they'll they'll run on a
a campaign and they'll be like line by
line item in a build that doesn't even
[ __ ] exist like what are you doing
you're not you're not going to win with
a message of a line item on a bill that
doesn't exist try try making sure that
your constituents know that what they're
doing to P to children who are gay
children who are trans women in the
state of Texas women in the state of
Missouri they want to take their [ __ ]
Liberty away I think there's that's it
folks they want to take your Liberty
away they want to they want to take your
consent away from you for your children
they want to marry your children
so go check out I'll retweet this so
it's at the top of the timeline so you
can find it but go check out go follow
at dirty moderate and go follow Adam on
Twitter
that's at the top of this tweet and then
check out that episode on April 15th we
have a great discussion about our
country the state of our country's
politics
um you guys wanted to see the uh
let me show you this uh here we talked
about this yesterday a little bit
here it is here's these two [ __ ]
there's the two guys
in The Villages that receive community
service
there they are right there
there they are right there
right chair
and again
in Texas there was a young lady she was
black and that's why she was given a
prison sentence because she was black
you can't convince me otherwise
you can't commit me you can't can't
convince me otherwise let's go to the
Tweety tweets and the trendy Trends here
let's go to the trends of course Elon
Musk is still trending it number one
because we know why he wants to attempt
a Twitter coup
yeah
um another topic that's trending Is
Dianne Feinstein the senator from
California
the stories are out of Washington and
this is uh been known in Washington is
what these stories are are saying
is getting bad our bad is getting worse
uh with Dianne Feinstein losing your
memory apparently her AIDS and people
around her her colleagues staff of her
colleagues are saying look now Diane
Feinstein is is not okay
um let's see what Lawrence O'Donnell
says here he says I understand concerns
about Dianne Feinstein but Reed whispers
about her in the Senate context
at least 50 senators are 100 dependent
on staff most senators are 90 dependent
on staff and Strom Thurmond died in
office in 2003 at the age of 100 after
and after a obvious mental decline
so what what Lawrence is trying to point
out here I'll retweet this
um what Lawrence is trying to point out
here is that most of the time the
Senators memories and what they're
writing and what they're saying is not
exactly
um
it's not exactly their words they're 100
percent
uh
they're 100 relying on their staff and
that's where these whispers are coming
from because she's not apparently she's
not she's not remembering conversations
she's not able to hold her memory
um I believe Diane Feinstein is 88 years
old I believe
um if I'm if I read correctly this
morning
she's 88 years old now a lot of people
out there are making the case for uh
term limits which this is really [ __ ]
dumb
I anytime I hear someone talking about
term limits I'm like you are a and I I
don't even care if it's a liberal I'm
like you are a dumb [ __ ] we have
term limits
we have term limits folks they have a
limit on a term
they're not elect the only people that
are that don't have [ __ ] term limits
are Supreme Court Justices and federal
judges those are the only ones that
don't have term limits
they're appointed to a lifetime
appointment
the only ones Congress people they have
a two-year term limit
I mean it's up to us to limit it right
like this is really [ __ ] stupid we're
like oh if it was up to us they'd have
term limits it is up to us
how don't you know this about a republic
we we live in a democratic
constitutional republic we vote in
States for not just your congressperson
but your Senator your Governor your
Lieutenant Governor the president United
States for [ __ ] sake there is a limit
on their term
now they don't have a certain amount of
terms right you can make that case you
can make that argument I guess
but we get to decide to extend their
term or not
like for instance Greg Abbott in Texas
Texas there are no term limits to a
governor he can be Governor from now
until the end of time as long as the
people of Texas continue his term limit
continue to extend it if that makes
sense
now come this November the state of
Texas can say well
your term is up your limit is up
it really does not make any sense folks
that we do not know this
so Dianne Feinstein as much as everyone
wants to you know get rid of her you're
gonna have the opportunity now it's not
going to be anytime soon because I
believe her term her next election is
2024 right
and if Dianne Feinstein's memory and
cognitive she's impaired cognitively
it's likely that she won't be able to
mount a very strong campaign and if
there's a very good
uh if there's a very good candidate in
place that can beat Dianne Feinstein in
a primary and that might happen right
now Ken says uh oh he send a Super Chat
thank you Ken he says your favorite turd
yeah
I wouldn't [ __ ] you you're my favorite
turd thanks thanks for the supers check
in uh but back to Dianne Feinstein if
there is a Challenger
in the state of California for the
primary then then they can mount a
campaign against her
and maybe the Democratic
and the party in in California can
decide that Dianne Feinstein's term is
up
and they can elect someone else to be
their senator in California right now
I'm not saying that there's not honor
and Dianne Feinstein saying her health
condition
is deteriorating and she needs to focus
on herself and her health and her family
and for her to resign her seat that's
not really going to affect us too much
in the senate in the short run
and the reason why is because we have
Gavin Newsom who is the Democratic
governor and the Democratic party
controls the choice
of who would replace Dianne Feinstein
and Gavin Newsom isn't going to appoint
a
a pedo Republican kid diddler that would
be my guess he's probably going to
appoint a Democrat to that seat
and I believe in the state of California
he can even appoint himself to that seat
if he wants I believe I'm not sure about
California some states have that ability
for the governor to actually appoint
themselves there's no limit to who they
can appoint
other than anything that's criminal like
we've seen with Rod bugoyevich in
Illinois
but the point is
that either way rather Dianne Feinstein
decides to resign because of her health
and we pick a replacement and then
there's a special election in California
and the people of California pick who
they want their Senator to be
or we just wait until the next election
that comes around because her term has a
limit a limit of six years
and when it comes around you can choose
a different Democrat to be in that seat
if there is such a Democrat that exists
to want to take that senate seat
this is how democracy Works how do we
not know this this is not a salacious
story this is not a scandalous story
every everyone wants to make Scandal out
of this
again like to Lawrence's point right
it's one senator in the Senate she holds
the seat she rightfully won her race
and she had staff that's helping her
yeah no it's not ideal right it's not
ideal to have a senator
who can't remember a lot of things and
remember conversations especially when
they hold very powerful seats because
they've been there for decades
and his powerful voice as Dianne
Feinstein has been and and is in the
Senate
my preference would be for for her to
consider this and make the wise decision
but it's her decision to make
you can't can't force her
and again the nice part is is we have a
term limit she's limited to six years on
her term that we voted her in our
California I should say
so stop with the term limit talk because
the other problem with term limits the
other real problem that we have with
turn limits is we would get more and
more Marjorie Taylor green and Lauren
bobert's in the Congress doubt me
we would get more of that nonsense more
of that [ __ ] because if you get rid
of someone who is a real policy maker
who's really [ __ ] good at it who's
committed to being a policy maker and
working for the American people and you
limit them to one term two terms and
then they're gone
you think that's going to help democracy
you think that's going to help the
people if they're a good policy maker
and they're really good at it they're
serious about it they make good
example Katie Porter
do you want Katie [ __ ] Porter to be
limited to terms hell to the no I want
Katie Porter to fight fight from us in
this country not just for her District
but in this country
for a long goddamn time long time I
don't care if she's a congresswoman or a
senator I really want her to stay in
congress
possibly the Senate and the reason why
man maybe that's a good idea Gavin
Newsom if Feinstein resigns maybe uh
maybe Katie Porter but the point is is
that Katie Porter is important and the
reason why she's important is because
she knows how to ask questions she knows
why policy is important to exist
you get rid of Katie Porter because of
term limits get the [ __ ] out of here
with that [ __ ] Jamie Raskin you're gonna
get rid of a Jamie Raskin because you
just can't handle not going and voting
that's what you're gonna do
come on
this is nonsense this term limit stuff
is [ __ ] they did it in Missouri
in my home state of Missouri
and it polluted the entire political
system here
with term limits and the reason why I
want to bring this up with this
Feinstein story because that's a real
story that the story of her
deterioration mentally is not that big
of a story she's 88 years old she's been
doing this for a long time generally
when you get older in age you have some
cognitive impairment
it happens
to a lot of folks when they get older it
does happen
that's some of the concern about having
an older person run for office
especially in your 80s in your 90s
but here in Missouri they pass turn
limits back in the 90s and everyone
thought oh my God that's a brilliant
idea brilliant idea to pass to pass term
limits then these crooked politicians
can't be CR well if they're crooked
politicians vote them the [ __ ] out
vote him out vote them out
you got a governor in the state of Texas
it's clogging up the [ __ ] supply
chain so your grocery stores aren't full
vote him out vote him the [ __ ] out
in Missouri they passed in the 1990s
term limits
do you know what happened after they
passed her everyone was so excited great
now now we don't have term limits well
they just had an endless cycle of
buffoons and by the time these [ __ ]
morons would figure out how legislation
Works how to pass a bill the hard work
of actually doing the policy making not
running an election because as you heard
on the clip from Adam's show dirty
moderate I believe there are two things
in this country
when it comes to politicians there's
politics and there's government and
they're two separate things
running elections and winning elections
is different than making policy two
[ __ ] different things
two different [ __ ] things
and you don't get to make policy if you
don't win elections and if you're a good
policy maker and you're prevented from
keeping winning elections so that you
can deliver up good policy for the
people in your District or your state or
your country whatever it is
then that is a really [ __ ] dumb idea
a really dumb idea for democracy to let
someone who is a damn good policy maker
to be limited to how long they can make
policy because what happens is in
legislators where there's term limits is
by the time these [ __ ] idiots
and they are idiots because the pool
gets really thin you scrape at the
bottom of the [ __ ] Barrel when you
have term limits
and by the time you're scraping at the
bottom of the barrel for some
representative who's a no Namer whose
alls they're trying to do is make a name
for themselves in front of Lobby firms
because that's what it is by the time
they learn how to make policy in the
legislator
they know all the lobbyists at that
point and they can't run for office
anymore so guess what they do
they find them a special interest group
to go be a lobbyist because now they
know how it works they've seen it on the
other side they've seen how a lobbyist
convinces them
to pass bills and to do shitty policy
for special interest so then they go and
work for special interest and make all
kinds of [ __ ] money way more money
than they would ever make being a
legislator
so why in the [ __ ]
would we make it to where a good policy
maker is limited to the amount of time
that they have to make policy in this
country
we have real policy makers folks you
don't know their names A lot of times
because they're not famous they're not
on the [ __ ] TV shows
they're not out saying crazy ass [ __ ]
they're not out trying to make a name
for themselves
they go to Washington
to make serious policy for the American
people and their constituents
that's what they do
they're very [ __ ] serious
about making policy for our country and
progressing our democracy
for equality equity and Liberty it's
[ __ ] important [ __ ]
it's what makes the whole engine run
and to limit terms
is is ridiculous to say oh any term
limits we don't it's we have term limits
folks we have them if your
representative is shitty and they
[ __ ] suck go vote them the [ __ ] out
do that
that is how democracy works
okay let's let's go back to the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends I'm going to
get off the Feinstein
box here uh we are 13 minutes into the
second hour you know we do two hours
every day every single weekday we do two
hours here on YouTube Twitter twitch go
to the YouTube page if you're over on
Facebook and give us a give us a
subscribe like
you know comment or whatever whatever
you're supposed to do on YouTube
if you're on Facebook and your new
listener go subscribe over on YouTube
just type in the Tony Michaels podcast
we appreciate you joining us from
Facebook the Midas touch Facebook page
because we air live
on the Midas touch Facebook page YouTube
Twitter twitch
every single weekday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific
every one of them Monday through Friday
let's do this let's take a quick break
and we'll be right back
with the shitless Roundup to to round up
all the Tweety tweets and the trendy
trends of the day right after these
messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slim Jims skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again
here's Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
here's Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
looks like there's some breaking news
[Music]
this will not surprise a lot of you
[Music]
and all
like at all at all
the governor of Florida
uh that Nazi bigot Ron DeSantis has
signed a bill to take away women's
Liberty
oh not surprising I mean that's the only
thing they can really do at this point
like
I mean like I I would love to be a fly
on Mike Pence's hair I mean just to fly
on the wall is what I meant
when they're having these legislative
meetings about the legislation that they
want to pass in States
like when you like to be in that room
because they're like okay
okay so what you're saying is this bill
doesn't take away anyone's Liberty it
doesn't discriminate against anyone how
is this bill ain't Thai gay does this
bill allow us to marry children because
if it doesn't if it's not anti-gay if it
doesn't discriminate against someone if
it doesn't take someone's Liberty away
and if it can't allow us to marry
people's children we don't want it get
that bill the [ __ ] out of here we just
don't want any of that kind of [ __ ]
in our negotiating room about
legislation that we have
literally that's probably what happens
I don't know for sure but I would
imagine that's what's going on over
there
Florida Governor breaking an Associated
Press says yeah if I can make this let
me get my zoom right and Santa Jesus
you think I'd be able to figure this out
yeah sort of Breaking Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis assigned a 15-week abortion
ban into law the move comes amid a
growing conservative push to restrict
abortion ahead of the U.S Supreme Court
decision that could limit the access to
the procedure Nationwide
I mean we've seen Oklahoma basically
Banning outright right
just absolutely banned it outright like
you can't get an abortion at all in
Oklahoma now you will they will get
abortions
she can't legally they're making it a
felony
and if you don't think that uh women are
going to be are going to get killed
in Oklahoma because they can't have a
safe medical procedure where you're
[ __ ] fooling yourself
their lives are in danger because their
Liberty is in danger
the autonomy of their body is a danger
here that's the [ __ ] point
I guess a recount here has um
I have the signing let's see what this
uh
is this yeah this is this is about an
hour ago it looks like
let's see let's see what this [ __ ]
Nazi does let's see if he says anything
[Applause]
look at the little girl next to him
she's like you piece of [ __ ]
you piece of [ __ ] you're trying to take
Disney away from me you [ __ ]
you're the you're the enemy of Mickey
Mouse and you're trying to take my mom's
Liberty away you [ __ ]
she's not happy look at her she's like
what are you clapping for [ __ ] this
[ __ ] look at her look at her she's
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] him
trying to take Mickey Mouse away trying
to take my Liberty away from me [ __ ]
this guy she even knows
she knows
and someone's like hold up the sign God
damn it act excited she's like no
he's trying to destroy Disney he's
trying to take away Encanto
let's not talk about DeSantis
oh I love I love I love the
little girl giving him the [ __ ] stink
eye here you know the the anti the
anti-micky mouse
anti-disney
Disney's woke they Disney doesn't want
us to discriminate against people how
dare they
[ __ ] idiots
so here the Nazi bigot uh from Georgia
Georgia Florida just south of Georgia
the dick-shaped state of Florida
south of Georgia the governor Ron
DeSantis
is signing a bill
into law Banning abortion 15 weeks
taking women's Liberty away taking their
right to their to their medical autonomy
and their bodies away from them
of course he does
of course he wants to take their Liberty
away from them he is a [ __ ] fascist
oh we want freedom the freedom to
oppress your rights and your Liberty
that's what we want the freedom of
we should have the freedom
to oppress you and to take away your
rights women lgbtq
Black Folk that's what they're doing
it's what they're doing
and they're going to continue to do this
uh Finland is uh in the trends
Uh Russian warns of nuclear deployment
if Sweden and Finland join NATO so
Russia is really amping up the threats
this is almost probably as serious as
the threat of Elon Musk uh buying
Twitter I'm dead serious Russia is not I
just don't see Russian launching nuclear
weapons it's not in Vladimir Vladimir
Putin will not exist
if he does that
again and the key of independent here
says Russia's threat to deploy nuclear
weapons
in the Baltic if Sweden joins Finland or
Sweden Finland joined NATO
uh Deputy head of Russian Security
Council said that Moscow would have to
strengthen its defenses in the region
there can be no more talk of new clear
free baltics
so they're then veiling a threat of
nuclear nuclear attack
again it's about as much of the threat
of Elon Musk buying Twitter that's my
belief now we have to take it seriously
because this Vladimir Putin this
murderous dictator he's a [ __ ] Maniac
he's a goddamn maniac
we have to take him seriously
because he could I mean he could push
the button
it happens
that he has the power to push the button
on the nuclear weapons in Russia
speaking of Vladimir Putin and Putin
let's go watch this uh Putin's party why
we're speaking of that do
you guys know who's in Putin's party you
guys aware of that
um I said is Elon Musk and Putin's party
I don't know I'm just surprising here I
figure if Putin if there was a Putin's
party which there is a Putin's party
here in this country it's called the
Republicans
the the grand old party of Putin the
Jeep GOP
let's listen let's listen to this
Putin's party from Midas Touch Russian
State television has been featuring
Tucker Carlson show where he
demonstrates his strong support for the
Russian invasion of Ukraine why is it
disloyal to side with Russia but loyal
to side with Ukraine Moscow is also
widely reporting on former president
Trump calling Putin a genius for
masterminding this attack on our Ally
this is genius Putin is now saying it's
independent a large section of Ukraine I
said how smart is that and he's going to
go in and be a peacekeeper inexplicably
the party of Reagan Mr Gorbachev teared
down this wall
has become the party of Putin and why
shouldn't that root for Russia which I
am smart I mean he's taken over a
country for two dollars worth of
sanctions I'd say that's pretty smart
can we give a ride of laws for Russia
remember that celicity is involved
remember the Ukrainian government is
incredibly corrupt and it is incredibly
evil there is no win for Ukraine here uh
Russia is being very successful in their
Invasion uh we had a kind of a really
pathetic uh display from the Ukrainian
president zielinski earlier today the
GOP is
party
Fox News is Putin's propaganda
shameful sickening traitors
[Music]
they are Putin's party and they are
traitors
and their their ideas to tear down our
democracy in the name of Putin because
that's what Putin's trying to do all
around the world
he's trying his best to destroy
democracy because democracy is their
enemy folks authoritarianism really
hates democracy they [ __ ] hate it
because it's their demise
it's their demise
so don't turn away do not
turn away
to Ukraine
um as as the Russians threaten to launch
nuclear weapons if Finland and Sweden
joined NATO
um
speaking of NATO let's go watch this
[ __ ] video too
Jesus Christ this Putin party [ __ ] never
ends like they don't they don't it
doesn't end they [ __ ] they love
Vladimir Putin because he's an
authoritarian and they love Putin
because he wants to tear down democracy
they [ __ ] and love him they [ __ ] love
him listen to this [ __ ] even Sean
Hannity
even Sean Hannity last night on his show
tried so [ __ ] hard tries his
damnedest
to get the former guy
Donald Trump the Cheeto dust mobster
Putin's little [ __ ] Putin's puppet that
is Donald Trump
tries to get him to say yeah what
[ __ ] Putin's doing as war crimes and
it's despicable
listen to what this [ __ ] bonehead
says listen to this you can't look away
don't look away I know this is hard to
listen to because it's Sean Hannity
and Donald Trump but you cannot look
away it is so important that you know
what the [ __ ] they're doing and why
they're doing it listen I asked you the
last time you were on whether you think
that this is evil in our time do you
believe this is evil or not the last
time you were on I had you on the last
time and asked you if it was evil and
you couldn't say that it was evil that's
why I'm asking you again hint hint say
that it's evil dumb [ __ ] say
that Putin is evil say he's a murderous
dictator say he's a piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] say that he should not be in
control of any country anywhere say it
out loud if you're gonna say anything
and listen to what this dumb
[ __ ] says time
I think in a hundred years people are
going to look back
and they're going to say how did we
stand back and NATO
stand back which in many ways I've
called a paper tiger don't forget I
rebuilt NATO because oh my [ __ ] god
this lying sack of [ __ ] [ __ ] he did
nothing did nothing did nothing
but tear down NATO try to destroy NATO
for Putin
look this idea that [ __ ] Putin
wouldn't invade Ukraine
if Trump was President maybe he wouldn't
why would Putin have to invade Ukraine
if if Donald Trump was handing him
Ukraine
why would he have to invade if he was
handing him Ukraine
by tearing down NATO and not letting the
Neo allies protect Ukraine this is
really [ __ ] dumb folks
the reason why Russia is threatening
today to launch a nuclear attack is
because NATO exists and Sweden and
Finland are trying to join it and it's a
threat to Russians autocracy Putin's
authoritarian rule
so this bone-headed [ __ ] idea that
NATO isn't protecting Ukraine is really
[ __ ] dumb
really [ __ ] dumb and the only reason
why he's saying this nonsense is number
one he's a buffoon but the one thing
that this buffoon knows is that Putin
hates NATO
and Putin is Putin's enemy is NATO it's
an alliance of democracies got it
it's an alliance of Western democracies
to protect democracy NATO is not
intended to protect land yes that land
lives inside of a Sovereign Nation that
is a democracy NATO is designed and is
an alliance to protect
democracy from authoritarian murderous
dictators
where do you [ __ ] think NATO came
from you think we just pulled it out of
our ass
no it came after authoritarians were
trying to take over the entire [ __ ]
world
committing genocide
like an Auschwitz now in in bucha in
Ukraine executing innocent [ __ ]
civilians
because you want to do a great real
estate deal as Donald Trump puts it in
Putin's party the Midas touch video oh
man what a great deal for two dollars
worth of sanctions he's getting a whole
country what a great real estate deal
and now here on Fox News Sean Hannity is
putting a softball on the tee
to knock that [ __ ] out of the
park
and he can't he can't even bring himself
not even bring himself to say that the
genocide that's happening in Ukraine the
the murdering of innocent civilians the
war crimes that Putin's authoritarian
regime is committing in Ukraine in a
Sovereign Nation he can't even bring
himself
to say that it's atrocious
it's vile
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
when I became president the first thing
I noticed when I went there to the first
meeting was that most of the countries
were not paying or were paying far less
than they were supposed to there were
only eight out of 28 countries that were
paid in full the United States was not
only one of them we were making up the
deficit in order to protect Europe we
were paying possibly 80 and that's the
rub did you hear him we're paying all
this money to protect Europe that's why
he's such a [ __ ] idiot
he's such a dumb [ __ ]
because he doesn't understand that NATO
is designed to protect the democracies
that control those Sovereign countries
that have those borders that have that
land it's the Democracy the idea
the freedom and the liberty of those
people who live on that land not the
land itself these [ __ ] these [ __ ]
authoritarians can't think about
anything but material nothing nothing is
human to them no Humanity in anything
not a [ __ ] thing
this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
percent of NATO to protect them and then
they take advantage of us yet on trade
because on trade their every bit as bad
as China here we go more murder murder
is happening
folks murder is happening in Ukraine
murder genocide Vladimir Putin
is killing innocent civilians committing
war crimes
and here he is here he is thinking that
NATO NATO is designed to protect trade
he doesn't even understand without
without Western democracy without the
protection of record Western democracy
with NATO
that trade doesn't even exist you dumb
[ __ ]
Europe might not even exist you dumb
[ __ ]
Putin's enemy is democracy
autocracy
and democracy are mortal enemies
and that's why they are Putin's party
that's why that's the choice you have to
make this year in the midterm in 2022 in
America
in your state in your county
you have to make that choice do you want
autocracy do you want Putin's party the
people who are okay with the real estate
deal in Ukraine because it's a great
deal for two dollars worth of sanctions
we're getting all this land it's a great
deal and [ __ ] Putin's so smart for
murdering all those innocent women and
children and committing war crimes for
this land because by God that's a most
important thing
Putin's party are you going to choose
democracy are you going to choose
autocracy
do you want to choose the Republican
pedocon kid diddlers who are trying to
take your consent away from you for your
kids and trying to marry them
trying to sexualize their gender at
every turn and at every Point that's
what you want
is Putin's party
well good luck I'm on the side of
democracy and so is NATO
and that's why Sweden and Finland and
Ukraine are trying to join NATO
is to protect Western democracy
democracy is not perfect folks
the Democracy in Ukraine is not perfect
our democracy is not perfect
there is no perfect democracy that's
actually sort of the point
is to keep striving until you reach
Perfection which you never will
again that's kind of the point
is to make progress where every progress
can be made
with humanity and the people and rights
and Liberty
let's play the rest of this buffoon
and then we'll get to the video that
everyone wants me to play apparently
there's a a video that everyone's
wanting me to play they agree to this
very badly on trade we changed a lot of
that around but they were very tough on
trade I asked Angela Merkel how many
Chevrolets are you selling this month in
Munich
or Berlin and she looked at me well
probably none I said you're exactly
right son and yet we had the
Mercedes-Benz of the Volkswagen that all
of them we had to all of the German
companies and the same thing with
Farmers our Farmers sell virtually
nothing to Europe you take a look at
what we sell and yet we take their
product they treated us very badly in
trade and we defended them and we really
if you look at the real numbers I'll bet
you it's close to 80 and I said you have
to pay
yeah I must have needed myself sorry
sorry is this the video that everyone
wants me to play is this the one is this
the one
no sound everyone's saying no yeah I got
it I got it unmuted now see I pulled the
Gabe I pulled the gape it happens it
happens every once in a while
when you have um when you have uh when
you're trying to run stuff you're
yourself is this the one and everyone's
saying yes okay
so this is this is the video that
everyone wants to see is it a song is
that what this is
I'm just trying to make sure what the
hell I'm playing here
is that what this is is a song
okay we're gonna play a song here we're
gonna play a song
here we go
many months of taunts and lives of
teenage Army standing by General
stuttering and replying sync up and
surviving just a fight Kremlin orders
definitely been bumping down with them
sirens group in the whole world watching
scream stop shooting go [ __ ] yourself
[Music]
democracy when are you clean Blood on
the crunchy spoon Instagram
yourself foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go [ __ ] yourself
[Music]
[ __ ] off [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my God
thank you very much for sending that
that's a fantastic video uh Robin says
she tried to send it yesterday
and she says oh my God I tried to get it
on the show yesterday I just love it
it's fantastic it's a good it's a good
video it's a great song I don't know
does someone does someone have the uh
the ringtone yet
does anyone have the ringtone yet
of go [ __ ] yourself Putin go [ __ ]
yourself I love it thanks for sending
the uh the go [ __ ] yourself video okay
let's go see what else is uh what else
is happening oh wait wait wait wait wait
wait I gotta I Gotta Give Eugene credit
there
I know Eugene Eugene's a good guy let's
see let's give him let's give him credit
here I don't want him not to get credit
we'll retweet this for him
give him credit it's not on the screen
but I'm giving him credit I promise
thanks for your thanks for your Tweet
Eugene
all right
thanks for your tweet that day let's go
back to the Tweet tweets and stranger
and see if there's any more breaking
news we're 40 minutes into the second
hour now Grassley is trending uh
African-American is trending
um Greensboro is trending what is that
trending for Washington Post is trending
uh Texas governor is trending of course
said you know Texas is trying to out
Florida Florida and Florida is trying to
out Texas Texas
um dude let's see why Washington Post
does anyone know why that's running
um
Washington Post column was frightened by
the prospect of Elon Musk buying Twitter
this is the really stupid I'm not even
going to go in and not doing this again
I'm not doing this again with the Elon
Musk [ __ ] Jesus Christ I had to name the
episode I had to do the first what 30
minutes
with that [ __ ] incel that King of the
incels the in-cell Pied Piper Jesus
[ __ ] Christ okay let's go to
Greensboro let's see why it is trending
um news and observer checks fact checks
uh Joe Biden's speech as he discusses
inflation in the economy engineer
Greensboro North Carolina always going
to Greensboro apparently
I guess I guess he's going to Greensboro
okay well I'm great he's going to
Greensboro fantastic to give a speech
that probably is that good for America
uh why is Chuck Grassley trending I'm
going to get to the Charlie Kirk video
to hang tight I promise I'm going to get
to the Charlie Kirk we're 43 minutes
into the second hour but we're going to
get there
we're gonna get there someone says audio
oh you must be back up you must be uh
behind
behind
let's see here why is grantly trending
it's because he said something [ __ ]
stupid
it probably is speaking speaking of term
limits and electing old [ __ ]
into office maybe Iowa should heed the
advice of Californians by electing an
old [ __ ] into office I'm just
saying I'm just saying maybe maybe you
should take a hint
um with the the old ass wrinkly ball
sack that is Chuck Grassley
um what why is he trending why why
um is it this here video thread of
interesting moments of Chuck grassley's
Town Hall
um first the newsy one
Monday Grassley saying he no longer push
to repeal ACA Okay let's listen to this
uh people on the Affordable Care Act and
two of those happen to be my adult
children
and um I noticed in the Cedar Rapids is
that that you voted
um 12 times to try to repeal this yeah
before night before 2016.
and so I'm I'm wondering if the
Republicans you and the Republicans get
back in power is that again going to
come up to be repealed and if you do
what what is the Republican plan to
provide affordable health care for my
children it's not revealing the
Affordable Care Act if that's your
question so are you saying that you were
not saying I would not
we're not going to repeal the Affordable
Care you and all Republicans well I'm
gonna there's just there's 49 numbers
Chuck Grassley is a lying [ __ ]
that's what I have to say about this
clip he's a lying [ __ ]
he will absolutely if he gets the chance
absolutely if he gets the chance
to repeal the Affordable Care Act
because he can say I tore down Obamacare
he's lying to this lady in this town
hall lying to her face because he's a
republican that's what he does that's
what they do they lie to him to their
face
um yeah sometimes Amanda she says uh up
the video volume sometimes I don't I
don't have control over the video volume
it's the video that's being placed
because this person with this cell phone
was standing so far away from these
folks that their microphone wasn't
picking it up so I can only Up the
Volume so much it's tough sometimes when
you have these videos
that's that's why sometimes you have to
be choosy
um
so
anyways that's why Grassley is trending
I guess because he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
a liar he's a liar
he's he's a liar Chuck ragley is a
[ __ ] liar okay um
let's go one more time to the uh true
socialist trending of course
you talk about spoiling truth social's
plans if if Elon Musk actually does
um think about this
in the interest of trump if Elon Musk
actually does by Twitter full stop and
then let Trump back on Twitter you think
true social is going to execute the [ __ ]
out of here
come on there won't be any true social
besides true social was a pump and dump
just like this [ __ ] scheme that Elon
Musk is trying to run on the American
people and his band of Misfit in cells
well let's see if there's any breaking
news I think the only breaking news that
we had this hour was um uh the the Nazi
down in Florida the Florida governor Ron
DeSantis
is is taking away women's Liberty this
morning with the stroke of his pen okay
let's go back to the timeline I want to
show this um
I want to show this video of uh Charlie
Kirk oh it's fantastic we went on and on
yesterday with the video of Ben Shapiro
you remember that and I'm going to show
you this video this Tennessee
um Congressman too and before we head
out here we are 45 minutes into the
second hour we got 15 minutes left here
here is the Charlie Kirk video Gabe says
who wants to hear Gabe was not able to
join us today folks I don't know if you
noticed that but here Gabe is with his
tweet he said who wants to hear an
idiotic take from Charlie Kirk no
well here it is anyways
oh my God this guy just can't quit he's
such a [ __ ] bonehead doesn't he look
like a bonehead look at this guy look at
this [ __ ] guy look at him ah
all right let's let's listen to his
fantastic idea about the higher the
building the more liberal it is let's
hear we have a huge housing crisis in
our country the likes of which we have
not seen in a long period of time yeah
no [ __ ] Sherlock but I believe that we
need to build horizontally not
vertically yeah we need to build
horizontally not vertically I'm going to
tell you why he's what he's saying is
racist I'm gonna tell you why just hang
on it's one of my speeches developers
don't like it when I say this yeah
developers don't like it when you say it
because if you want affordable housing
you have to be efficient about it but
yeah go on you [ __ ] idiot but it's
true the higher the building the more
liberal the voter it just the higher the
building more liberal the voter what
does he mean does he mean the people
that are building the buildings or the
people they live in them hmm I wonder
what he's saying let's listen this so
and if if you are the closer to the
ground you are the more conservative you
are the closer to the ground you are so
you mean all we got to do is [ __ ]
make all you idiots take dirt naps and
you'll be content on being conservative
fine with that [ __ ] we should we
should encourage people to spread
horizontally and not vertically look at
Denver the higher the high rises has
never become less free or more free it's
become a dystopian nightmare you guys
know that now you might say Charlie
that's a correlation of the causation
think about it if you're on the 32nd
Floor renting not owning if you're not
in the weeds and in the yard and
understanding what it takes to grow food
into me okay let's back it up just a bit
here let's listen the causation think
about it if you're on the 32nd Floor
renting not owning if you're not in the
weeds and in the yard and understanding
what it takes to grow food and to
maintain the land
do you hear what he's saying he's saying
you need you need land in a yard so what
he's saying is that affordable the the
affordable idea that he is right his
affordable idea is to have land in a
yard and not to rent you dumb
[ __ ] most people in this country
don't they can't afford to own property
that's why they're building high-rises
you dumb [ __ ] for people to rent
sometimes to own but more than likely to
rent
for an affordable price he is really
stupid are you gonna be more or less
likely to actually be a conservative the
higher the building every single study
shows they become more liberal over time
it's happening in Phoenix happen in
Denver happened Atlanta happened in
Dallas happened in Chicago have
everywhere and yet few people actually
everywhere there's skyscrapers
everywhere there's really tall buildings
there's a bunch of lip cards oh oh my
God
okay hey you want to know how this is
racist because this is [ __ ] racist
he's talking to a room full of white
people you know what these white people
here yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] all those
ghetto projects that's that's what
they're thinking that's what they're
thinking they we need to have people
living in houses with yards and suburbia
and white folk white folk is what he's
saying
that's what he's saying white folk can
afford to buy property white folk can
afford to own land that's what we need
to do we need to have white folk owning
land
and get rid of all these high rises it's
affordable housing stuff we don't need
that affordable housing stuff those
people shouldn't have houses in the
first place
that's what he's saying that's what
these people in the room are clapping
for I mean
if Donald Trump followed this speech up
with he builds the biggest tallest best
apartment buildings ever they're the
most beautiful high rises in the country
they would start clapping
two different things two different
[ __ ] messages and they would clap the
same way and they would cheer the same
way and the reason why is because they
understand what Charlie Kirk is saying
here
they understand what Charlie Kirk is
saying here
they understand what Charlie Kirk is
saying
is that more more buildings that are
higher that rent apartments more black
people that's what he's saying
that's what he's saying to this room
full of white folk who are [ __ ]
racist they didn't come to a turning
point USA event because they believe in
a quality and Equity folks they did not
they did not buy a ticket to go to a
turning point USA speech
thank you
to hear to hear great words about equity
and equality
and liberty no they heard they went to
hear why White America is good and why
big tall buildings in Black America is
bad
because he's saying it's happened all
over Denver uh Phoenix all these cities
are getting all these high-rises you
know what these certain types of folks
in them with these liberals these
libtards black people that's what he's
saying it's code word
doubt me go go ask your racist ass white
cousin go ask him what Charlie Kirk
means by this go ask him
just just put this video on your phone
go ask him when he thinks Charlie Kirk
means by this
that's what Charlie's saying is we need
more white Suburbia and less black
high-rises that's what he's saying
and it's a Trope it's a dog whistle to
these [ __ ] white people in the room
that are about to load his pockets about
to load the turning points USA Pockets
because again if Donald Trump were to
walk in the room if Donald Trump would
have walk in a room right after Charlie
Kirk and start talking about the
beautiful high-rises that he builds and
all these great liberal cities they'd be
like Yay he's such a good business
person I'm so glad I voted for him
aren't you Cheryl he's such a good
business person shut the [ __ ] up get the
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
Charlie Kirk is saying he doesn't want
black people to live in high rises
that's what he's saying
that's what he's saying
and what he's saying is he doesn't want
affordable houses
he doesn't want affordable housing for
black people when he's like oh we don't
want those high-rises we shouldn't build
up because it's efficient and it makes
it more affordable to build up and make
it more efficient makes it more
affordable for the people who would
actually have to rent in those buildings
let's make it unaffordable let's spread
it out let's make sure they have to buy
a ton of land a big huge five acre lot
to build a house that way they can't
afford to live in that in that
neighborhood we should do that that way
they can't afford to live in our white I
mean our neighborhoods
that's what he's saying
and anyone who doesn't think that is a
[ __ ] bonehead and here's the proof
Gabe shows it
he says you were saying Charlie Kirk
here's a God damn tweet from 2016 folks
September 26
2016 8 41 pm
Charlie Kirk tweets Trump got rich by
creating phenomenal buildings and
structures
Hillary got lit Rich by selling out
America to foreign adversaries
so he's all for phenomenal buildings and
structures and the high rises the
apartments that are rented you know like
the [ __ ] apartments that Donald Trump
and his father discriminated against
black people in in the 1970s
that's right they did that in those high
rises and those big huge tall apartment
buildings those liberal apartment
buildings
you people are a bunch of [ __ ] idiots
who believed this guy who believed this
garbage
God damn you can't you can't stop with
the stupid you just can't stop okay
let's go to this uh Tennessee let's
um we're 54 minutes into the second hour
here
we're gonna watch this one last thing
representative Gloria Johnson she was
actually on the Midas touch podcast
talking about the several Tennessee
Congress people who are [ __ ]
pedophiles who are known pedophiles
convicted pedophiles
and they're trying to marry children in
Tennessee and pass laws to where they
can marry children in Tennessee it's
really [ __ ] weird but here she says
Tennessee senator says Hitler made
something of himself after being
homeless and you can too he says this in
this [ __ ] video that Hitler made
something of himself homeless people you
can too
I'm going to have to apologize for the
universe for this guy holy [ __ ] let's uh
let's watch this bonehead talk about how
he loves Hitler oh geez it's it's it's
brutal but we gotta watch it figure I
have it giving you all the history
lesson in a while and I want to give you
a little oh a history lesson he's going
to get a
a republican is going to give us a
history lesson well this should be just
[ __ ] brilliant after what we just
heard from Charlie Kirk oh my God it
should just be riveting history on
homelessness not Tina oh this guy this
guy knows about homelessness too oh this
Rich ass republican from the Strawberry
Plains District 8 Frank nicely
this rich white old wrinkly ball sack
he's going to teach us about
homelessness let's let's hear
10 Hitler decided to live on the streets
there you go let's let's back it up you
heard that right you heard it right
history on homelessness yeah 19 and 10.
yeah Hitler decided to live on the
streets for 19 and 10. he was around he
was [ __ ] he was he was in high school in
1910.
what the [ __ ] is this guy talking about
19 and 10 and Hitler decided to be
homeless
let's listen what else this ball Zack
has to say they're decided to live on
the streets for a while so for two years
Hitler lived on the streets and
practiced his oratory and his body
language and how to connect with pizzas
and then went on to lead her life that
got him in the history book so okay so
here's the thing
this guy obviously is a dumb [ __ ]
and he's a he's a goddamn pedocon
Republican kid diddler who was a goddamn
fascist because he loves his history on
Hitler
and you you know you know you know you
you know a fascist when you see one when
they completely [ __ ] up Hitler history
they completely [ __ ] it up like they
destroy Hitler history because he says
in the beginning in 19 and 10 right
that's 19 10.
right the year 1910 okay
and just rewind the clock a little bit
if you think about 1910 and then and
then think about think about what Hitler
did
during the first world war right he was
in the first world war and then in the
20s that's when he entered the Nazi
party
so he's saying he's saying before
before
the first World War
before he became a soldier in 1910 he
was practicing his oratory and trying to
become a Nazi if you know anything about
Nazi Germany and you've done your
[ __ ] studying and looking up on
history
you Senator nicely you dumb [ __ ]
you would know you would know that it
wasn't until after
Germany lost in the first World War
that Hitler started to practice his
oratory
and began to develop himself as a rabble
Rouser
in the in the Nazi party which wasn't
even called the Nazi party in the
beginning but it became the Nazi party
people really are [ __ ] dumb and the
thing is they want everyone else to be
dumb with them
let's listen to what else this [ __ ] has
to say all these people it's not a dead
end they can come out of this these
homeless camps and have a productive
life or in Hitler's case a very
unproductive life
uh all these homeless folks can come out
of can come out of these homeless camps
and be Hitler I get I don't know what
the [ __ ] he's trying to say I have no
idea number one he doesn't know what the
[ __ ] he's talking about when he's
talking about Hitler history again
that's when you know for sure that
there's a fascist afoot when they can't
even get the [ __ ] history of Hitler
right like the timeline 19 and 10. oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] guy
thanks for joining us today on the Tony
Michaels podcast we really appreciate
you joining us here and you can join us
live
every single weekday
every one of them you can join us here
on the Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube
Twitter and twitch
and now coming to you live from the
Midas touch Facebook page every weekday
Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
live don't forget to go subscribe to the
YouTube channel because if you miss it
live it's okay
it always lives over on our YouTube
channel so search the Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube subscribe to the
YouTube channel so you do not miss an
episode and if you want to listen to the
episode that's fantastic too it's on all
the directories every last one of them
Apple Google even the boycotted Spotify
it's on there we don't boycott ourselves
here at the Tony Michaels podcast we
post our podcast on Spotify so go check
that out over on all your directories
and while you're there on the
directories leave us a good review five
stars not a bad review offset some of
these trolls these trolls have been
going over and you know giving bad
reviews so we need some good reviews
over there go over and give us some good
reviews while you're there
so download it on all your directories
go to YouTube re-watch
and yesterday was a good episode today
was a good episode but yesterday we had
on KFA
Karen agnivolo of legal AF and yesterday
they had a great episode check that out
on Mindless Touch YouTube page
as well
thank you for joining us today on the
Tony Michaels podcast we will see you
tomorrow noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific again right here on YouTube
Twitter and twitch and now from the
minus touch Facebook page until tomorrow
Surfs Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] em
[Music]
foreign